Hồi chừng dí sản thân hoa xuất lịch ở thu công liện Nhạy Van ông Saiye,
Grasas, Sully, Amirui, cho biết một chăm bà miếm 1 dinh tích lịch sử tại 2 miếng thành thành đã bị hình
hại sau có của tấn công và Tee Van Chong là giống Mỹ và Israel tiếng hại.
Phong tên này đúng ông đưa ra khu phòng bân về hãng thung tấn thật hòa sã.
Theo ông Sully, Amirui, của tên Van Chủ thì thành nặng nơi nhất với sống hiệp bà dịch tinh đẹn hưởng.
Bà hồn nhiều diễn sang có sát chỉ lịch sử và phán hoa.
Quán chừng này đồng thời gie chỉ có của tấn công đã gây tổn thật nghiêm trọng được bây sản quý Van.
Tee Van đã gửi thư tự nhiêu tổ chức của tế trong đào có lý được quốc và UNESCO,
kêu gọi tăng cường chú ý và hành động nhằm bảo vệ dí sản bân hoa.
Vì ở răng cho sang tần có phản mạnh mấy hôn tự cộng được của tế trước các thi thạy này.
Để mấy mấy vệ sửa trưa ra bình luận chính thức về các cám bộ.
Giờ qua xanh nhận định, cuối xung đột kéo xài không một tháng sử Mỹ Israel bởi và Iran,
đần ra phép nước lợ về việc bảo tổn dí sản bân hoa, trong thử chến.